c'est nommons macho man vous allez
devoir maintenant écouter avec les jurés
et les auditeurs aussi on espère le
terrible l'implacable réquisitoire du
procureur de la république générale est
proche
ces pauvres hélas
[Musique]
et canepa
on
est ce que je veux dire une chose avant
que oui mais si le pokémon bouton
justement va en parler je vais justement
je voulais en parler justement jouissez
de la vie monsieur mort shuman il est
beaucoup plus tard que vous ne le pensez
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri j'ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le faire remarquer
ici avec le brio habituel qu'une
caractérise pour être procureur on en
est pas moins homme et sous la robe rose
terre de la vie
il y à quoi ces trois posters il ya un
petit haïtien
non un petit pull over de chez nous à
nyon
à chaque fois que vous parlez de votre
robe la honte m'habite jamais comme si
j'allais aussi bas je me suis allé aussi
pardon tard il y a 6 et 3 milliards
d'hommes il y à un homme comme vous ou
madame messieurs dames
j'ai juré un homme comme vous monsieur
le président en hausse alors là un homme
comme vous mais en plus beau m'être rego
et cet homme que je suis est aujourd'hui
d'une humeur massacrante tremblay et
mortimer schuman ça va saigner
pourquoi suis-je d'une humeur
massacrante
parce que la troisième guerre mondiale
est proche parce qu'à des milliers
d'enfants des millions d'enfants meurent
de faim dans le monde
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que ça me
foute parce qu'il fait froid ça fait
rien j'ai un petit pull non mesdames et
messieurs les jurés si je suis d'une
humeur massacrante mesdames et messieurs
les jurés c'est parce que j'ai un petit
bouton rouge là ça va très bien que tu
as robe longue pour ce que évidemment
c'était pas très radiophonique pour ce
nos auditeurs qui n'ont pas la chance
d'avoir la couleur ils peuvent
évidemment pas s'en apercevoir
mais si les caméras de monique des
barbares veulent bien zoom et un petit
peu merci monique voyez vous chers
auditeurs vous voyez bien là c'est là
c'est un petit bouton rouge et c'est
insupportable
je ne vois que ça et c'est d'autant plus
fâcheux cadre aux sciences c'est
d'autant plus fâcheux qu'après cette
audience se doit à participer à une
émission de télévision intitulée le
procureur voit rouge
c'est ma fête or il n'existe au monde
que deux médication efficace pour lutter
contre les petits boutons rouges sur le
nez des procureurs de la république
française premièrement applications de
peaux mates à l'or et aux missiles pour
calmer la douleur
deuxièmement application de la peine de
mort à l'encontre de l'accusé pour
calmer la mauvaise humeur
je n'attendrai donc même pas la fin de
mon réquisitoire pour aller acheter de
la pommade divers et et réclamé la peine
capitale à l'encontre de mort qui merde
schumann ici présents et croyez bien
monsieur schumann que ce le fait sans
aucune haine
puissiez-vous landru ou bernadette
soubirous et elles mêmes tarifs
voici donc une affaire classée mesdames
et messieurs mais puisqu'il nous reste
encore quelques instants avant
l'inévitable plaidoirie de l'avocat
commis d'office
posons-nous ensemble une question qui
était mort cuman qui aime qui est morte
wii qui est moralement il se peut en
effet que lorsque cette émission qui est
enregistrée sera diffusée sur les ondes
la sentence ne soit pas encore appliquée
ça dépend du non parce que là on a
bourreau cgt il je crois qu'ils
engraissent précaution bref là n'est pas
le sujet à ce propos et pour répondre à
un courrier de plus en plus important je
rappelle que les exécutions capitales
son public bien sûr mais dans la limite
des places disponibles
les places sont à retirer auprès de nos
charmantes hôtesses tous les jours si
possible avant l'aube dans le grand hall
de radio france 116 avenue du docteur
guillotin du résident quelque 1000 guide
un guide et kennedy sur le 16e c'est un
spectacle inter
rappelons également qu'un buffet froid
sera servi impressionne exécutions
capitales
on peut apporter sans manger il ya de la
bière vous n'avez pas fait ça nous
rappelle le bon temps bien qu'ils aient
mort shuman le président villers qui
perd son temps à chercher des chefs
d'accusation avant de juger les gens
c'est ce vieux cartésianisme rétro qui
vous colle à la peau c'est ce besoin de
logique
le président villers pense que mort
schuman est un agent de la cia en ans
dont dix passés il ya on dit si elle est
plus chic de même que nous disons
d'ablis aussi field et non pas chaude
fields parce que maintenant en amérique
à nice tout c'est vrai ça me rappelle
d'ailleurs ce journaliste de radio dont
je tairai le nom
par souci de charité situe parfaitement
authentique ce que je vais vous dire
cet homme annoncé il n'y a pas très
longtemps dans un journal parlé que les
pourparlers paix entre l'egypte et
israël avait été ajourné sine die
c'est vrai il y en a un rôle assez bref
c'est vrai il y en a d'ailleurs un autre
qui a parlé comment s'appelle le peuple
qui s'est électrocuté kaboul voir ce
qu'il y avait à les utiliser les doigts
dans le bougeoir l'autre dans le pôle 6
à possible là bas il a devancé la mort
de paul v un journaliste j'aimerais moi
aussi alors bon morte schumann brahms
schumann est il un espion américain à
cette question je réponds
qu'est ce que ça peut [ __ ]
si c'était un espion russe certes ce
serait fâcheux car qu'on le veuille ou
non les espions russes sont plus ou
moins communiste mais un espion
américain mesdames et messieurs les
jurés
qu'est ce que vous voulez qui nous
piquent comme secret d'état la recette
du coca cola prenons au hasard l'un des
messages secrets que mort shuman
destinait soi-disant à la 6ième et que
nos services ont réussi à intercepter
qui lui tend allô papa tango charlie
reconnaissez les fêtes monsieur choi
vous reconnaissez veille oui bon alors
allô papa tango charlie et bien crédit
foutaise moi j'ai décrypter moi même ce
texte c'est un simple petit mot destiné
à tino rossi papa tango c'est tino rossi
est évident allô papa tango ça veut dire
à l'autre tino vieille crapule
prostatique
quant à charlie quant à charlie d'après
les officiers des services secrets
français du chiffre charly06 urgent
arrêter en gaine lancinante
insupportable et enflure essais signés
du mouvement de salubrité publique ccc
contre les corses chantant dont les
visées politiques sont bien connus du
public c'est un comité qui luttent pour
l'interdiction de petit papa noël sur
les ondes sous prétexte que ça fait
soixante dix ans que l'on entend nuit et
jour sept comme ses chansons pendant six
semaines par an on ne peut que mépriser
ce comité dont maurice schumann
d'ailleurs est le président d'honneur et
qui veut donc zigouiller tino rossi
cela dit si ça vous arrange monsieur
schuman je peux vous avoir 50% de
réduction sur le plastique si enfin si
vous en prenez au moins 10 kg pour être
sûr de ne pas le rater
là ce qu'on voudra 10% on pourrait même
revenir sur la peine capitale si vous le
croyez vous en la légion d'honneur si
vous faites certainement les honneurs à
la place de la peine capitale c'est tout
ce que je demande pour mort shuman c'est
non non
[Musique]